[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
dans le 7-8 loisirs vos idées sorties
dans le département on commence ensuite
avec le sommaire la fête du conte
revient pour une nouvelle édition dès ce
week-end nous recevrons la responsable
des médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines pour nous présenter le
programme jusqu'au 6 décembre entre
fable et réalisme la ferme de bel ébat
propose buffle la ville de saint john
bull free qui doivent affronter la
jungle de la ville et prendre garde aux
lions enfin les rebonds ont désormais
leur temple dans les yvelines le premier
parc à trampoline du département a
ouvert à l encours nous sommes allez y
faire un tour
jusqu'à mercredi une quarantaine
d'artistes franciliens exposent leurs
oeuvres à l'espace albert camus dans le
cadre de pastel en yvelines une première
édition à maurepas pour ce salon
consacré aux pastels mais qui existe
déjà depuis 2012 au chesnay 130 tableaux
sont à découvrir le vernissage et la
remise de prix ont lieu ce samedi à 20
heures on écoute la présidente de
l'association pastel en libye nous
présenter cette technique picturale dans
le pastel ce sont des petits bâtons de
pigments de couleur et on utilise cdc
doit on travaille avec ses doigts à la
peinture ça va être un couteau ou au
pinceau mais là on travaille directement
avec la matière on arrive à faire des
glacis on arrive à mettre de la lumière
à rajouter
des valeurs enfin c'est vraiment très
agréable de peindre pastel ce soir et
demain la ferme de bel ébat propose une
pièce de théâtre entre conte réalisme ou
buffle une fable une fable urbaine
pardon raconte l'histoire de cinq jeunes
buffle livrés à eux mêmes dans la jungle
de la ville
bâtiment quand il avait 8
5 buffle perdent leurs frères la veille
de ses 9 ans alors qu'ils tentent de
faire leur deuil le père et la mère
disparaisse eux aussi ils se retrouvent
livrés à eux mêmes face au lou sait
comment ses cinq enfants en fait arriva
à essayer de s'en sortir suite à ces
différents drames comme les fables de la
fontaine comme l'unesco en fait la
métaphore animalière pour pouvoir parler
mieux des humains
[Musique]
e
s'est approché des bougies
et
[Musique]
en
fait les lions représente vraiment la
société les dangers de la société les
coups durs aussi et tous les dangers sur
lesquels les bus doivent faire face et
comment en fait il sait aussi se mettent
ensemble vraiment troupeau pour pouvoir
résister face à selongey écrite par pao
miro en 2008 c'est la pièce pioche dans
les genres du polar et du drame familial
la mise en scène épurée et poétique est
un hybride entre fable et réalisme là
vraiment on est dans une forme qui
déplace complètement le théâtre on est
dans une fable c'est un compte il ya
très peu de dialogues deviennent avoir
trois dans la pièce le reste c'est
vraiment que des personnages qui essaie
de raconter au passé au présent ce qui
leur est arrivé essayer de vivre avec ça
c'est vraiment le souvenir c'est comment
il arrive à vivre avec ce souvenir ses
souvenirs difficiles alors c'est pas
dénué d'humour 1 c'est une pièce qui est
assez noir sur pas mal de choses mais il
ya quand même une vie extraordinaire et
comme j'ai un travail de metteur en
scène très corporelle c'est quasiment
chorégraphique c'est quasiment dans ces
cinq personnages pour cinq points de vue
différents sur la famille et une morale
à retenir la jungle s'affrontent
difficilement 101 3
[Musique]
rêver voyager laisser divaguer votre
imagination avec la fête du conte à
saint quentin en yvelines la 16e édition
commence demain pour petits et grands
avec nous véronique paulhan merotto
directrice du réseau des médiathèques
pour nous parler de cet événement dont
jour véronique - jour alors que
pouvez-nous dire un petit peu qu'est ce
que c'est que la fête du conte qu'est-ce
qu'on pourra retrouver saint quentin en
yvelines alors la fête du conte c'est
vraiment un événement fédérateur pour le
réseau des médiathèques de saint quentin
en yvelines c'est une opération qui se
mène depuis de nombreuses années puisque
nous sommes à la 16ème édition et
nous nous travaillons ce sujet sur
toutes les médiathèques du réseau les
sept médiathèques
aussi au travers notre notre bibliobus
et puis également avec des partenaires
que ce soit le théâtre du prisme la
bibliothèque universitaire pour la
première fois cette année et puis
les scolaires qui sont qui nous
accompagnent chaque année donc l'idée
c'est de proposer des comptes un petit
peu tous les jours dans toutes les
médiathèques du réseau de saint quentin
en yvelines oui de proposer des contes
tout public sur le réseau des
médiathèques mais également
d'aller
on proposait et en
réaliser
que ce soit
au prix où ou dans les classes et
également des spectacles il ya également
des spectacles cette année vous avez une
conteuse associés pour la 16e édition
nathalie leones que pour nous la
présenter qui est cette menteuse oui
cette année pour la première fois on a
décidé de travailler
avec une conteuse plus particulièrement
et de quelles soient un peu le fil rouge
de notre de notre temps forts
et ça tombe bien parce que nous sommes
sur le thème du temps cette année la
thématique c'est le temps c'est le temps
que des comptes en rapport avec cette
thématique alors pas que mes
on a essayé d'en rattacher le
possible
[Musique]
d'où notre petit loup qui se promène
avec une
avec une grosse horloge qui est la
mascotte je suis de là serait rendu
compte de la fête du peuple plusieurs
halles a du coup été domo sur la fête du
conte s'adresse au grand public mais
aussi aux scolaires et aux
professionnels voilà
le grand public et le tout public
puisque on propose des contes pour les
tout petits mais également des comptes
la plupart du temps c'est aussi d un
public très familial les parents
viennent avec les enfants les grands
parents peuvent venir également et on
on travaille également avec les
scolaires au travers
les comptes en classe qui sont déjà
menées depuis
maintenant plus d'un mois dans les
classes avec un coût des compteurs qui
sont des conteurs
bénévole non professionnels les conteurs
de trappes ou les auteurs du bois joli
et ses actions de comptes en classe vont
amener les enfants et leurs leurs
enseignants à venir écouter des contes
dans nos médiathèque un dernier premier
dj sur les rendez-vous alors rien rendez
vous immanquable du coup c'est celui de
demain la médiathèque anatole-france à
attrape c'est le lancement de cette
nouvelle édition voilà à la médiathèque
anatole-france là les bibliothécaires se
sont s'engage
avec nathalie leone qui les accompagnent
pour pour monter ce spectacle et demain
anatole france les bibliothécaires
raconte
pour lancer ce cette nouvelle saison
d'accord bon bah c'est noté en tout cas
dans les agendas surtout ne pas manquer
le lancement de cette nouvelle fête du
conte merci à véronique de nous avoir
présenté à cette fête du conte à saint
quentin en yvelines et la totalité du
programme est à retrouver sur le site
internet merci à vous on quitte les
médiathèques pour une sortie un peu plus
sportives désormais on peut jouer au
basket ou à la balle au prisonnier sur
des trampolines le premier parc à
trampoline des yvelines a ouvert la
semaine dernière à elancourt nous sommes
allez y faire un tour regardez
[Musique]
cmh et comme les grands noms de la nba
sauter sur un muret faire l'acrobate
odom barque offre au public
ouvert depuis seulement une semaine le
premier par 4 en polynésie been fait
déjà des adeptes chez dia mais avec
notre temps et je trouve que c'est bien
tu peux sauter tu peux faire des saltos
et tu peux faire plein de trucs on
attendait un ensemble comme ça parce
qu'il fallait aller dans le 92 ou ses
premiers ennuis à côté de notre club
donc forcément ça attire les jeunes le
club salue attire nous la cua autres
faire pas mal de choses là des éléments
qu'on n'a pas dans le club donc ça nous
permet pour nous de vous perfectionner
amateurs et professionnels se côtoient
dans cet espace de 1500 mètres carrés
équipée d'une trentaine de trampoline la
mise en place a pris deux mois pour
pouvoir proposer différentes activités
le prisonnier d'une fosse à cuba un
concept découvert aux états unis par le
responsable c'était une expérience j'ai
testé par hasard l'activité on vient
jump et entre potes en famille
physiquement ça demande un minimum de
d'entraînement ou un minimum de physique
donc effectivement je sens que les gens
s'attendaient pas à ce que ça va c'est
dur mais sont très contents et
reviennent du mardi au dimanche les
jumper sont attendus dans l'arène ne
comptait 12 euros pour pouvoir se
défouler prendre une heure le temple
dureront propose également des formules
anniversaire pour les enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre rendez vous dédié aux juniors
cette semaine nous vous proposons une
activité manuelle à faire en famille le
1er décembre c'est jeudi prochain et ce
jour là n'oubliez pas d'ouvrir la
première case du calendrier de l'avent
mélanie poker va nous donner des idées
pour le réaliser soi même bonjour
mélanie bonjour camille je sais pas je
ne sais pas vous mais de mon côté dès le
début du mois de décembre j'ai qu'une
envie c'est d'être le 24 parce qu'en
général le réveillon c'est l'occasion de
se retrouver en famille déguster un bon
repas et découvrir les cadeaux déposés
par le père noël également au pied du
sapin oui c'est ça qui fait que le plus
dur c'est d'attendre d'où le calendrier
de l'avent première question aussi
camille qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans le
vôtre alors moi je reconnais que j'ai
opté pour un calendrier de l'avent très
simple du chocolat pour faire classique
mais c'est vrai qu'au dans le commerce
on en trouve de différentes marques de
différents dessins animés sous toutes
les souches ou les cibles si on peut
dire mais vous avez nous donner quelques
idées pour pouvoir en avoir un
personnalisé personnalisé c'est ça c'est
le mot ou voile résultats sur la table
j'ai pas fait les 24
les vingt-quatre dates parce qu'il n'ya
pas assez de place mais il y en a bien
sûr à faire chaque jour du 1er au 24
décembre plusieurs styles j'ai fait des
cadeaux ça rappelle les piquets de
dusapin ça fait encore plus attendre la
première étape il faut trouver des
patrons de quoi faire soi même la boîte
si ça correspond pas à la taille de vos
petits cadeaux vous pouvez aussi le
faire il faut calculer ça fait un petit
peu de mathématiques aussi on sait
jamais il faut aussi choisir du papier
cartonné qui permettra de faire les
boîtes derrière un petit peu de
souplesse c'est plus facile pour plier
on a moins de surprise quand on a des
toutes petites mains quand on est un
enfant du papier cadeau pour emballer
quelque chose qui vous plaît dieuze
coach de la colle des ciseaux lassé des
ciseaux un peu pointu les enfants le
bourg où ça passe très très bien et pour
numéroter les cadeaux pour rappeler
l'esprit du calendrier de l'avent des
petites étoiles de différentes tailles
et du coup vous imprimez les patrons sur
les feux de couleurs ensuite vous les
découper c'est ça on découpe proprement
parce que l'autre vont pas dans des
petites surprises aussi quand on va
plier après on prie chaque très visible
voilà on sait ce qu'on voit à l'image on
fait ça calmement comme chaque figure
permet meilleure boite et ensuite vous
collez vous scotcher tout ça est la
boîte est formée mais surtout avant de
la fermer complètement qui il faut
surtout pas oublier la petite surprise
alors justement des petites idées
cadeaux connaître à glisser dans l'est
dans ces boîtes alors moi j'ai choisi un
petit nounours ça rappelle ça permet
aussi de décorer le sapin ça fait
attendre encore plus noël des chocolats
des bonbons des petits jouets et si
jamais les enfants se décident de faire
un calendrier pour les parents pourquoi
pas des petits mots doux ça fait
toujours plaisir il faut surtout penser
à celui ou à celle qui recevra le
calendrier il ne vous reste plus qu'à
l'enveloppé d'un beau papier cadeau du
choix le même différent et donc du coup
on peut aussi faire différentes tailles
en évidemment là on envoie des plus gros
des plus petits et si on sache un peu au
niveau des idées qu'est ce que vous nous
conseillez a deux solutions sont
possibles la première c'est tout
simplement internet le web regorge
d'idées j'ai trouvé des trucs super
sympa on a des sapins en papier on a des
boîtes chinoise des maisons histoire de
recréer un vrai village et même du bingo
il s'agit de chercher et de piocher l'a
carrément au hasard et puis pour ceux
qui voudraient un peu d'huile et aussi
des ateliers saint quentin n'est pas en
reste il y a accueilli en cours au pont
du rock thouarsais samedi 26 nommant
toutes les informations de l'atelier
sont à retrouver sur le site de la
commune merci beaucoup mélanie poquet
pour ses idées de calendrier de l'avent
qui on l'espère vous aideront à
patienter jusqu'à noël on passe
maintenant à notre agenda les rendez
vous à ne pas manquer ce week end
[Musique]
ce dimanche sous une bâche géante est
organisée à bois d'arcy l'événement est
organisé au profit de l'association un
geste en plus les fonds récoltés
serviront à financer l'équipement de
deux personnes handicapées la présidente
de l'association nous en dit plus sur
cette journée
on a donc dit profs qui viennent on a
aussi créé un cours spécial à mobilité
réduite tout handicap confondu personnes
âgées voilà on l'adapté pour eux donc ça
commence à 11h30 jusqu'à 12h30
donc ça c'est vraiment un cours qui est
peut-être un peu plus soft ensuite à
partir de 14 heures jusqu'à 17 heures on
a vraiment des cours plus intense en ait
dit prof c'est la fameuse statue de
loisirs merci de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro 10 il a très bon week-end
à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]